more quantum welcome to the science
Asylum I am Nick lucid my quantum video
was very popular and I got a ton of
comments asking for more three of them
specifically asking for the uncertainty
principle which is constantly
misinterpreted the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle or sometimes just
the uncertainty principle is usually
written as an inequality like this where
this is the uncertainty in position and
this is the uncertainty in momentum or
motion oh and one more thing it's wrong
really
it's wrong who are you to challenge that
the principle the interpretation what
you normally hear is something like this
the more you know about where a particle
is the less you know about what it's
doing this implies that somehow the
technology were using to make
measurements is at fault nonsense it
shouldn't even be called the uncertainty
principle because it's not really about
uncertainty it's about randomness it
should really be called the Heisenberg
randomness principle the proper way to
write the principle would be like this
these two things here are not
uncertainties they're standard
deviations together they're always
bigger than this Universal number since
it's really small we don't ever notice
it in everyday life it's only important
for really tiny things like protons and
electrons wait wait what's the standard
deviation that's a little complicated
what we really need is some context on a
quantum level all particles are
described by wave functions probability
waves these little particles are
inherently random but some are more
random that others depending on the
circumstances particles are a little
difficult to picture so let's use me
right now you might feel pretty
comfortable explaining to someone where
I am on the screen I'm in the middle but
what if this happens to me where am i on
the screen now everywhere in quantum the
standard deviation measures this spread
for particles it tells you something
about how well you can predict what a
measurement will be so this principle
says two things one will never be able
to predict either position or momentum
perfectly and two if our chances of
predicting one go up then the chances of
predicting the other go down in other
words if the wave for motion looks like
this then the one for position looks
more like this meaning it doesn't even
make sense to ask where the particle is
a typical electron inside of an atom has
a wave function that looks like this
which is the size of the entire atom
it's not that we don't know the position
it's that it doesn't have a position
additionally the principal doesn't just
apply to position in motion just about
anything you can measure about a
particle is involved in at least one of
these inequalities energy lifetime
angular momentum spin and even sometimes
mass mass yep
particularly for neutrinos that's crazy
seriously crazy however just like how
relativity is about things that are not
relative the uncertainty principle is
really about things that are not
uncertain or random it's about the
things we can measure precisely together
with principles that don't look like
this or this but look like this so what
was the last thing you weren't sure
about please share in the comments and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy
you